I was ordained for some great purpose in
the hands of the Almighty
nat turner was an enslaved African
American preacher who was born in 1800
and led a large-scale resigned in 1831
that trans Ultima goes in the system of
slavery he chose violence as his only
option and then option painful and live
as it was shook up the system neck
Turner was a mind-blowing experience to
white culture and change the game in a
fundamental way
they vowed before they started the
revolt that they would kill every way
person they saw men women and children
they were done being dehumanized they
were done being treated as property and
they just rebelled the rebels followed
kind of a zigzag path they thought that
most of the houses along the way killing
the slaveholders and their families who
they found there
the judgment of this Court is that you
are to be taken into jail then to the
place of execution and be hung by the
neck until you are dead dead dead
lynching in America were spectator
sports nor spectator events people came
from miles around and bodies were
dismembered when people went to these
kinds of Affairs they wanted to take a
souvenir away that proved to everybody
that they were there and that that
person that monster is now no longer
alive and how do I know that because
I've got a piece of his body right here
[Music]